out there 50 miles wasteland in every  direction take it from me this world is  a harsh place anything could happen  we picture uh won't be too long now  you're gonna have to fit into what we do  here my rules are simple today it's  gonna be a good day I can feel it  [Music]  yeah I'm sure I don't have to explain to  you the consequences if you cause  trouble for me  [Music]  how old are you 15  called are you 19 do they know you that  old why what do they do  [Music]  so who you looking for the answer is  everybody  [Music]  help you you want to help me  you want to be a part of this yeah  nothing like the unconditional love of  an animal how much does he owe me 300  it's one of life's great pleasures I'm  asked if you were actually committed to  this you're missing  what is your shooter no you are